DAY-TO-DAY.
FOX AND LINDGREN OPEN SAVE MADEY
SHESTERKIN BRINGS CHEERS FROM
THE CROWD.
LEAGUE.
TAKEAWAY AND SHOT BY GOODROW WAS
STOPPED BY PUCK.
FINDS LUNDQVIST TO STROME AND
SAVE MADE
AND THE RANGERS GRAB A 1-0 LEAD.
WHOA!
WHAT A SAVE MADE BY SHESTERKIN.
HE LOOKED BEHIND HIM ON
PLAYER.
>> Sam: SHOOT.OFF.
KEPT IN BY WEEGAR.
THAT HIT THE POST BY EKBLAD! A
LITTLE BIT OF ROOM AND FAKES TH
STOP BY SHESTERKIN!
HE GETS KNOCKED DOWN! WITH FIVES
IN THE PERIOD.
THAT SHOT,GHT.
ARTEMI PANARIN MAKES IT 3-0
RANGERS!T GOING TO MISS
A WIDE OPEN NET.
3-0 RANGERS!.
>> Joe: THERE IS SPENCER KNIGHT
THERE.
NO
OFF THE BOARD.
>> Joe: OKAY.END-TO-END AND WHA
FINISH!
IT'S 3-0 RANGERS! TOGETHER AND
LITTLE FLIP OVER THE SHOULDER.
HERE IT COMES AGAIN.
HERE IS THAT EXT FAKE THE THIRD
UNDERNEATH HIM.
RANGERS CAME CLOSE! SCORED ON
YOU."5:46 TO GO.
THERE IS THE PUCK AT THE POST. S
CUT THE RANGERS LEAD TO 4-2.
>> Joe: THEY
SHOT, HIGH
IT'S SUDDENLY A ONE-GOAL GAME! .
HE JUST -- ZIBANEJAD GOT THERE
AND THOUGHT HE HAD THE